you know when i came to sample i already
had managerial experience i was an
experienced professional but in many
cases uh
that experience did not matter because
when you switch from
an industrial american conglomerate into
a japanese
insurance company that wants to
transform itself
it's very different so many of the
things that
you're used to or that you assume that
you know
best but not really effective welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with c-tec
working with israel and japan meet
inandolev
ceo of sampo digital lab israel sompa
holdings
inon is the ceo of sampo's digital lab
in tel aviv
sampo is japan's largest insurance
company which also operates a chain of
nursing homes for the elderly
his group is responsible for partnering
and investing in startups in areas such
as ensure tech digital health smart
mobility and agritech
prior to that inon spent 13 years at
general electric in various management
positions
he established ge's company's startup
partnership program
which included 26 startups italian holds
a ba in computer science from the
interdisciplinary center in israel
and an mba from cornell university
inandalev good morning welcome
to 20 minute leaders how are you hey how
are you michael
you're not calling from japan although
you're working with japan right
that's right i'm actually coming from
tel aviv unfortunately due to kovaneti
and i haven't been to japan in over a
year and a half
wow and so you know
there's a few things that i want to get
through in these 20 minutes both about
your personal journey and
you know the unexpected nature of of
your
specific journey but also talking a
little bit about the japanese market
and how is an israeli you're now working
with you know with the conservative
enterprise from from japan
and insurance and and opening up the
digital lab here in israel but also you
have best experience with general
electric and and
mba from cornell and so tell me a little
bit first about your journey
about how you look at you know yourself
over these years proceeding through the
different opportunities
how much of it was planned how much was
it was unexpected and what sort of
guided you throughout your journey
sure well you know most of the good
things that happened to me in my career
i never planned for they actually
occurred
starting with my first position as a
software engineer in the startup company
in which like many people
i was invited to join by my commander in
the
millennium the reserve duty who was the
head of r d
a few years later i decided to get an
mba at cornell university that's
always been my dream to have a business
degree from
american university and i thought that
after i actually
go back to high tech into you know
silicon valley or something of that
nature
but then came general electric and said
hey your profile is
interesting we have this leader
program i think you could be a good fit
for and
at that time ge was a big successful
brand so i said
why not i'll try it and that attempt is
uh
taking place for 13 years it was a great
experience because i
used to do a lot of things in energy
healthcare
technology licensing he
moved me back to israel uh to lead its
startups in the partnership
program uh from 2015 to 2018 there was
the boom that i think of the iot
industrial space so i was uh
one of the founders of the local program
here
and then came a japanese insurance
company that
wanted to transform itself digitally
and change its business models by
establishing a local innovation team
and uh invited me to establish the sao
paulo digital in tel aviv
and i've been doing this uh for the past
three years
so it does i'm guessing it doesn't just
happen overnight or by complete
coincidence after understand how does it
actually happen that you're working for
general electric
in israel part of the israel ecosystem
and all of a sudden you find yourself
getting approached by a japanese firm
saying hey we we've i don't know what
but we're interested to work together
why don't you come and join us and
i'm guessing it's not the most trivial
mindset shift from you know general
electric
to sample
that's right it's very very different
both cultures
as well as methods of operation
you know at that time when i was head of
the startup
program at ge i worked a lot with
venture capital firms and other
partners and uh someone who's looking to
establish a team here
reached out to the local ecosystem to
the same venture capital firms i was
familiar with and i uh they received a
recommendation about myself and the
connection was made there was a good
chemistry
uh and very shortly after a few weeks uh
later i joined uh
sample i always had interest in japan i
never had any experience working
whether in japan uh but
uh you know it was a small child i read
the books about uh
japan and uh uh always had the interest
in the history of japan
uh and the country itself but never had
the experience so
to me it was kind of a risk but
something that i was uh
very intrigued by uh you know
to really try to uh morph uh
uh kind of a traditional financial
company
uh into becoming more digital advanced
but also
working with japanese and getting to
know the culture and the country
better and so uh you know it's been a
journey it's been very interesting
i'm studying japanese i have much more
experience now
i have friends in japan i feel like i'm
still learning a lot i'm not
i'm no expert by all means uh it's it's
fun
it's been fun if you look back at the
transition and some of the things that
you had to
to overcome or or change or understand
better
you know if you could talk to in on when
he was just starting out with sample
what would you tell him so what what are
some things that you learned
now that you've been there for quite
some time
that you know previously you just
weren't able didn't weren't able to
because you didn't experience this
transition yet
right uh so uh you know
when i came to sample i already had
managerial experience that was an
experienced professional but in many
cases
that experience did not matter because
when you switch from
an industrial american conglomerate into
a japanese insurance company
that wants to transform itself it's very
different
so many of the things that you're used
to
or that you assume that you know best
but not really effective but just to
give you an example
in japanese yes uh there's a lot of
hierarchies
right even in the workplace not only
among
superiors and subordinates but also
amongst peers there's all kinds
of uh hierarchies uh and in many cases
it just works so assuming that we
israelis or
customers know how to work best in an
agile environment and we can
do things differently uh is a little bit
arrogant so one of the things i had to
to do very
early on is to check the ego aside
uh check it out and understand that
there is different ways and means
uh uh when working with in japan or with
a japanese company
uh first learn them understand them
before trying to change them right
and so what does that actually entail
this understanding because it's not just
you know embracing yourself in the
culture and saying okay just give it
time understand
do you actually have to take proactive
steps to to try and understand them and
to really
embrace them or or is it is it mainly
just you know
just spending time being calm and
letting the energy
you know feeling the energy as you go
along
um i think it's really coming with a
mindset
that there are certain things that you
can learn
about how to do better from them but
also
realizing that there's ways and means
that
we bring to the western world that we
can help them
improve and so i'll give an example of
one thing that
i've learned a lot from my japanese
peers and it's all about
active listening and reflecting right
for example in japan
interrupting someone or having a
passionate discussion where people
yell it's very impolite
i've witnessed a colleague of mine a
senior
executive managed negotiations with
me in with an israeli startup
and it was very quiet
he tend to more listen and accept
information
rather than share his own mind and
try to impose the position on the other
side
and then quietly make a decision
and that was remarkable so for me
uh this is a great way of how to
achieve effectiveness and also
you know become a little bit more uh you
know humble
uh and uh less kind of aggressive
but still be effective
and i think what i'm hearing is one of
the challenges that you're not just
having to
make a mindset shift yourself and to
embrace the culture
and which a lot of this embracement is
not necessarily to change but also to
respect and to acknowledge
you know how one wants to be treated or
talked to
uh but also it sounds like in other
challenges as you're working on
partnerships between the israeli
ecosystem
and so you actually have to be sort of
this
messenger and and you know help the
israeli companies and israeli folks
understand
what they're entering this is not just
another zoom call
with the regular counterparts in the us
right
that's right that's very much the case
you know when you work on a big project
between an israeli
technology company and one of our
business units uh
in japan uh in many cases i found myself
me or my team
as mediators as or coaches
we have to explain to these really sort
of how do the japanese make decisions
and what would be what would be best as
far as to
how to approach them uh and by the way
vice versa
as well uh unfortunately i can tell that
you know the japanese have
people have no expectation of you
behaving like them and they fully
understand
that they're different and they're very
humble
about this and so and they also
understand
the intricacies of israeli culture
like the fact that we're very direct
interesting we're very casual
in many cases they're actually trying to
learn and embrace
some of those habits themselves
but you know every time i do a deal or
it's not only about the technology
or the the business opportunity it also
has a lot of a kind of a cultural
and topological aspect to it and you're
right it has a lot to do with kind of
coaching both sides on the
how the other side thinks
right tell me a little bit about also
tell me a little bit about the japanese
ecosystem
you know i i don't know anything about
that ecosystem how does it work and
you know i'm imagining that quite a few
people that are listening to this also
aren't really you know under
knowledgeable of what's happening on
that side of the world
sure so you know it's the third largest
economy in the world
uh and it's growing in many cases uh
there are some
social issues that uh have to be
resolved
uh in many cases biotechnology uh like
for example an
aging society a third of the population
is
elderly wow other elements in japan
are for example yeah that's right and so
there's a lot of issues related to that
from
healthcare all the way to you know
managing independence
or driving transportation mobility uh
cities in japan are becoming uh smarter
in embracing uh technology it's driven
by the government there's some
government subsidies and policies so
uh i think that in the next few years
we're going to see more
of the smart cities market in japan uh
booming
uh telemedicine and digital health is
going strong and what's interesting here
is that unlike the us where
you have local innovation like the bay
area or in boston
or other hubs in japan uh there's it's
much less so and so the country is
actually embracing
external innovation and partnerships
from outside effect
there's even a government office that
puts branches and offices in places
like tel aviv and others calling
entrepreneurs
to establish their business in japan
to establish a local entity it takes a
day
it's a very business friendly uh country
people usually are very honest and very
strict on fulfilling
the business uh terms like paying on
time
and uh they're very intrigued by the
innovation that
uh helps in israel one thing is
important to know the standard of
service in japan
uh is very high uh starting from you
know just a
restaurant on the street all the way to
large multinationals
and so if you're an entrepreneur or
investor and you want to enter the
japanese market
you have to think about the way you
provide service and support
at least as good as your product uh it's
not a sign right
it's you have to interest in it if
you're going to be successful
in providing service in japan you're
going to be successful elsewhere
in the world that's why i think it's one
of the reasons why japan is so
lucrative so those are some of the
characteristics of the japanese
ecosystem i'm glad to say that more and
more investors
and corporations from japan are putting
up footprint in
in israel and more and more
entrepreneurs uh
from israel are looking japan as a
viable market
did you ever think you're going to be
working with japan
you know at this point in your career
after
cornell after general electric is this
was this a part of any
any idea any motivation
had you asked me like five years ago if
i would work for a japanese insurance
company i would have thought you were
crazy
no chance but uh you know as i mentioned
many of the good things that uh happened
to me in my career
things that came my way that i wasn't
planning for uh
right and i'm glad they did so um
this has been quite a fun uh journey
and i've made a lot of friendships along
the way
and so obviously there are vast
opportunities as we have become more
globalized and the israeli market
becomes more and more relevant in every
possible space in the world
and there's going to be a lot of you
know a lot of
interesting partnership potentials
between countries is young entrepreneurs
it seems sometimes that we're in our own
bubble in our own ecosystem and it's
hard to
to see the outside world how what do we
do to
see these opportunities to get to be a
part of them
especially as these opportunities are
going to become more and more meaningful
as time goes on
um from my personal perspective
you come to people like me so my
team my group uh is very proactive
reaching out to the local ecosystem
in order to evangelize uh
what we're selling and so if you're
interested
in learning uh what are the main
challenges or how to operate in japan
or elsewhere by the way because our
company is global
then this is what we do for a living
and so with some research and reaching
out to people like us
to other japanese corporations to
japanese investors
you can pretty much get a good
understanding of the type of problems
you can solve
uh what does it take to do business in
japan how is it different than
elsewhere in the world
and i can tell you that i'll give you a
nice little anecdote
many of the companies if not the
majority of the companies they work with
now
are companies who are focused on the us
market
who initially told us no we said no
we're we have to be focused
we're only focused on the u.s market and
then we found
a viable business opportunity that they
couldn't say no to
and they understood that
the market in japan is something that's
a lucrative
environment that uh through partnerships
with companies like us or others
uh doesn't necessarily have to consume a
lot of
too many resources uh but still we can
penetrate that market so together you
know so
uh that's uh that's my uh
offering as to how to best learn and
immerse yourself in the
ecosystem in japan i love it and and
obviously
you know the painting behind you i think
it's it looks like it's a canvas from
from japan or at least somewhere in asia
right
you're right uh if you come to our
office to tell me and i invite you
michael to come and
visit us we're trying to give it kind of
a japanese
israeli flavor uh you have we have
both green tea and espresso so you know
it's kind of a hybrid environment
uh that we uh try to uh create for
ourselves
amazing uh you know i i know i love that
getting in a very small but meaningful
introduction for me
into into what you're doing and you know
i think
what you're describing here is part of
your journey is going to be part of many
people's journeys as time goes on and as
the israeli ecosystem opens up in a
meaningful ways i think in the past few
years especially we're seeing companies
emerge out of israel that are not just
dealing with you know the traditional
sas or cyber companies that we're used
to but but actually dealing with with
issues that are relevant around the
world exploring new markets
and so this internationalization and
this acceptance and embracement of
different cultures and markets i think
is going to be even more meaningful and
so
i have a feeling that i'm going to be
picking your brain for for quite some
time now also on a personal level
and so i appreciate definitely your time
and and i'm definitely going to come
visit the offices
i have three short questions left and
the first one is
your favorite subject in school
my favorite subject in school was uh
music because i'm a big music fan i play
a little music
and electric guitar it was always kind
of a
that's right yeah and so uh actually
yes that's right i played and i think a
little bit uh
though i'm not a good singer but it was
always a nice get away from the
daily you know school classes
and who would be one of your role models
or somebody that inspires you
in some way so speaking of music i would
say brian may the guitar player for
queen
uh it's not only because he's talented
in playing the guitar he's also an
outside the box thinker he designs his
own guitar
uh he plays a five
cent uh pick instead of just a standard
pick
and uh you know he has also a phd in uh
astrophysics
uh one really a good example of domain
building domain expertise
talent smarts and outside the box
thinking
i i haven't heard that one yet and i
love it and the last question is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
good listener a people's person
and a sense of humor i love it
thank you very very much and uh and i'll
see you in the television
thank you very very much take care bye